an economic crisis is looming and
experts are sounding the alarm afraid of
self-imposed Calamity treasury secretary
Janet Yellen is talking about the
dispute over raising the debt ceiling
which hasn't happened yet can't be
negotiated over whether or not we're
going to pay our bills but as the
countdown to potential Calamity ticks
closer to zero the U.S treasury is
buying America More Time by taking
so-called Extraordinary Measures because
if the government hits its borrowing
limit you have a real mess on your hands
so what are these Extraordinary Measures
how do they help avoid a crisis and what
happens when they run out
first it's important to understand what
makes them extraordinary the treasury
pays the country's bills by using
revenue from taxes because it spends
more than in taxes it makes up the
difference by issuing debt in the form
of government securities but there is a
self-imposed congressional limit to how
much of this debt the department can
issue that's the ceiling the only way to
fund a deficit is to borrow more money
and until it gets rid of the deficit
that debt is going to keep Rising it's
on Congress to raise that ceiling to
allow the treasury to issue more debt
and cover spending that lawmakers
already approved but there's a cap on
how much debt the department can issue
that limit the debt ceiling the debt
ceiling the debt ceiling if all this
sudden overnight you can't borrow any
more money well then you start missing
payments that you've promised this is
where the treasury comes in with its
Extraordinary Measures to prevent the
country from reaching the debt ceiling
the treasury uses these Extraordinary
Measures because it's got no alternative
if it can't borrow more money it's got
to find the money somewhere so the trash
accesses other funds it has tucked away
pulling money from one area to use for
more pressing spending needs in another
imagine that you have an envelope hidden
away in a drawer with a bunch of cash in
it to deal with a crisis this is the
envelope but how does the treasury get
that cash one way is by using money it
has stowed away for its own retirees on
January 19th Yellen announced the
treasury would be redeeming investments
from the Civil Service retirement and
disability fund and the Postal Service
retiree health benefits fund they are
one of the tools in the envelope pulling
investment doesn't shut down these funds
or mean that retirees won't get their
payments it does mean that these funds
will be tapped now while Extraordinary
Measures continue another way is by
pausing Investments on January 23rd
Yellen paused investments in the
government securities investment fund
which is invested in short-term U.S
treasury Securities in addition the
treasury can pause payments to
government funds that don't have to
immediately pay beneficiaries but the
treasury doesn't just take and pause
without refilling the envelope typically
after the debt ceiling is increased
they'll borrow money from the public
from Bond investors and then replenish
those pension accounts that it's taken
from however the treasury's
Extraordinary Measures are temporary
meant only to tide the government over
until a debt ceiling is raised the end
of the day Congress simply has to act to
raise the debt ceiling House Republicans
on the other hand want to use the debt
ceiling as leverage to force a debate
with Democrats about cutting spending to
curb future debt it doesn't matter if
you sit before a four-star general
they'll tell you the debt is the
greatest threat to this nation this has
become something of a recurring
political fight let's pay our bills not
torch our economy in the past they've
always raised the debt ceiling and tried
to get back to some state of normalcy if
they run out of funds in using these
Extraordinary Measures and they haven't
run the debt ceiling then they don't pay
their bills Yellen said that she
expected them to keep the government
from hitting the debt ceiling until
early June if the ceiling isn't raised
and the treasury can't meet all of its
obligations the U.S defaults it's called
The X date and it's never happened in
American history so what would happen
bondholders don't get paid interest
retirees don't get paid uh Social
Security funds contractors don't get
paid for military spending and then
you've got a real mess on your hands
that mess could cause a disaster in
financial markets it is possible for
markets to become quite concerned
about whether or not the U.S will pay
its bills before the Day of Reckoning
comes that could even mean a possible
credit downgrade one of the last times
we had a Moment Like This was standard
and Poor's downgraded the AAA credit
rating on U.S treasury Securities that
after witnessing a month of wrangling
over raising the debt ceiling they
doubted our political system's ability
to act there are real consequences if we
get to a moment where Extraordinary
Measures are exhausted and the U.S has
no way to continue to fund its budget
deficits the treasury says the U.S won't
reach the ex-state until this summer in
the meantime the treasury will continue
implementing Extraordinary Measures
until the debt ceiling is raised or that
emergency envelope is empty
foreign